Once we're registered for Piazza we'll
typically access from the Piazza link
on the left side of T-square.
We also highly recommend
bookmarking it separately so
you can go straight to Piazza
without bothering with T-square.
Here, we find the Piazza
home screen on the left
is a list of topics in the class.
Right now, the Class at
a Glance is on the right, but
as soon as we click on a topic,
the topic will appear on the right.
Across the gray bar, near the top,
is a list of folders.
We'll talk about those in a bit.
Across the blue bar, at the very top,
are three tabs, Q & A,
Resources, and Statistics.
Q&A is where you'll
spend most of your time.
It's where you access the forum.
Resources may list some
course information,
but in practice,
hardly any OMS classes use it.
Statistics will show you some
student statistics on the course,
as well as your own stats.
In the top left,
you'll find a drop down box.
You can use this to look
at a different course.
Finally, the gear in the top right
will let you modify your profile and
change your settings.
Let's start with your profile.